make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and it
is Thanksgiving week yes it is we are
going to be filling our stomachs full of
food and going Black Friday shopping and
I am going to Columbus to meet Mariah's
extended family and I am very very
excited if anything eyes want to follow
the experience like when I'm actually
out there and and meeting her family all
that kind of stuff go check out my
personal Instagram and I am rob
Jefferson I'm gonna be taking pictures
over the course of the week probably
throwing some videos up I'm very excited
so we're taking it easy this week right
we're just we're chillin we're relaxing
we're gonna take it easy and we are
going to cover one of my favorite
stories over the course of the week the
Thanos imperative this story is on Mary
thank you I love this story oh my god I
love that as a period let's get into it
let's skip over all the jargon and let's
get into it
okay so Thanos imperative is is really
like just one of the stories in a long
line of stories by Dan Abnett but I
always tell people the Marvel cosmic
landscape under Dan Abnett which started
with annihilation was amazing and it's
like this ridiculously amazing untapped
resource for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but you guys don't understand
the MCU like imagine movies like
infinity war and Avengers in game right
imagine movies like that except every
movie was like that and that's what
that's what the cosmic thing was right
you go from annihilation into an island
conquest into war of kings realm of
kings and then you go into Thanos
imperative you go into like all these
amazing stories and every one of these
movies would feel like Avengers in game
and like Avengers infinity war it's
ridiculously awesome but all this comes
out doesn't really even come out of
annihilation it all really comes out of
the war of Kings right in the sense that
you had Gabriel summers Falk in the 3rd
summers brother who's this omega-level
mutant who basically took off in a
shower space after learning that the
Shia are Emperor dick in was the one
responsible for the death of his mother
and where dick in had already had more
or less been defeated by that point vole
can basically use SERPs control of the
Shiar Empire itself this coincided with
the Inhumans who basically went into
conflict really blackballed engaged in
an honorable battle against Ronon the
accuser for leadership of the of the
creek and ultimately Blackwell proved to
be successful this is what you had well
you had Vulcan leading the Shiar
blackbolt leading the Kree and the two
groups came in to odds when the Shiar
wanted to expand his sphere of influence
outside of his own existing own existing
Galaxy missile as a result of that you
have this massive conflict that took
place called the war of kings between
the Shia and the Kree Empire led by the
Inhumans and in the midst of
conflict you had this detonation of a
bomb they created a rip in the universe
right he was called the fault is what is
what it was referred to you and the
result was that not a hundred percent
sure of what was on the other side what
you got were two things that went on the
first was this kind of guard post right
like the fault was turned into a
somewhat of a guard post in the sense
that like a garrison was left there to
monitor the fault and make sure nobody
went in and nothing came out the second
stage was to send in various
reconnaissance things right to either go
in there directly and take a look around
or to send in various drones different
things like that but to understand what
was on the other side and so what they
ended up learning was that on the other
side of the fault was called the
cancerverse
now those other guys who are reading an
ayah I think it's either annihilators or
annihilate is one of the stories at
Marvel is it's like a comic model just
released recently with the return of the
century that features the Ravagers
that's basically where all this comes
from is that like all that stuff comes
directly from this story and so they
basically ended up learning that inside
that universe nothing died right like
nothing was able to die everything lived
there and so it was kind of a cool thing
because essentially death died in that
in that universe now we will get more
exposition and more explanation that's
where the way the Dan ah Dan add the
tree things and so what it does is it
basically picks up with Thanos
immediately after the death or at least
seemingly after the death of his
character during the events of
annihilation when Drax the destroyer
ripped his heart out and so in the final
moments of Thanos his death basically he
ended up kind of joining the mistress
death for a moment and watch the events
of annihilation basically conclude when
Galactus had wiped out most of the
annihilation wave and then the rest was
just kind of cleanup duty but following
that mistress death mate Thanos immortal
she basically made it so that he would
never really die and so as a result of
that he ultimately ended up coming back
to earth he was captured by the
universal Church of Truth when Adam
warlock had put his body in a cocoon
following the events of annihilation
conquest and it was believed by the
universal Church of truth because of the
fact that they swore allegiance to the
Magus who's like a future evil version
of Adam warlock and the Magus usually
goes into a cocoon of sorts to kind of
regenerate his energies and whatnot
because they believed it was the Magus
they brought him back ultimately Thanos
ended up kind of coming back coming -
more or less emerging from this cocoon
but he wasn't really a shell of his
former self so much is just kind of
psychotic right he was sort of in like
this feral state almost and was
ultimately captured by the guardians of
the galaxy and that's what the guardians
are kind of kind of worried about here
right with the return of Thanos always
follows death it always follows some
conquest to get the the Cosmic Cube or
to take the Infinity Gauntlet or
something along those lines but some
desire to wipe out all life
existence right and where the Cosmic
Cube had previously been attained by
Thanos it's more or less fractured and
broken and not really usable anymore and
so as a result of this it's the question
of if Thanos is back what motivation and
scheme is he going to implement here in
order to basically conquer everything to
destroy as much life in the universe as
he can
that's the big concern that Guardians
have here and so as a results that what
you end up doing is you jump over to
Richard Ryder and this is when things
start to sort of pop off because
remember Richard Ryder is basically the
last of the Nova poor now he's the only
one left but what he's basically done
here is kind of a precursor to this is
there is a guy who is essentially he
looks like wendell vaughn quasar in in
Marvel Comics kind of a spacefaring
character who's really powerful
depending on who's writing him up but
this one while it does kind of have the
guise of Windell Vaughn it doesn't
really look exactly like him
and so he's considered to be the fall
swindle Vaughn and so essentially
Richard Ryder had been chasing this
version of quasar across the universe
from the planet Earth
he's kind of been racing towards the
Fault at the same time it's Richard
Ryder sending out an SOS to everybody
right just being like something's come
out of the fault and this is where the
universe starts to panic right because
people are like what is even going on
here right like I mean these things are
dangerous but like we don't know who
this guy is or what he's about it's the
first thing we've really had that came
out of the fault
that really like requires our attention
and so as a result of that you've got
the real main Marvel Universe Windell
Vaughn who responds you've got gladiator
of the Shiar empire who responds at the
same time that's happening suddenly all
these ships from the universal Church of
truth start popping up at the fault and
this is where people begin to panic
because the universal Church of Truth
they're believers right they're
religious zealots they believe
wholeheartedly in their cause of like
The Magus and so on and so forth and so
if the universal Church of truth is
showing up here nothing good can come of
this
and that's when Richard Ryder finally
catches up to the fake quasar and then
is ultimately confronted by Lord Magnus
where I can confronted by this evil
future version of Adam warlock a fight
breaks out between the two of them but
ultimately the world mine the kind of
source of power for Nova basically says
get out of there man because like this
fake quasar he's a little more powerful
than you this Lord Magus is way beyond
where you're at like there's no way you
can survive this and where he does kind
of stay behind you end up having like
Wendell Vaughn who actually shows up
finally and basically faces off against
Lord Magus where you have these things
kind of taking place in addition to all
those ships that are showing up from the
universal Church of Truth
suddenly it's planets this short start
showing up whole world start teleporting
to this fault and that's when Lord Magus
reveals his plan which was to detonate
all these
at the fault and ripped the fault open
and that's exactly what happens all
these worlds trillions trillions and
trillions of believers on these planets
all these worlds are blown up they're
destroyed and the kind of explosive
impact that it creates rips a hole in
the fault and basically allows
whatever's on the other side to start
passing through and that's when everyone
hits the panic button because it's
basically the worst situation because
then you have Thanos who breaks out of
his containment right you have everybody
else who's just like this is getting
crazy some guy kind of appears out of
nowhere and simply starts addressing
this false quasar and addresses Lord
Magus and says like there's everything
ready for the cleansing and ultimately
Lord Magus was unsuccessful in killing
Thanos the avatar of death meaning that
death still exists in this universe and
for his failure
Lord Magus is totally eradicated and you
end up learning this guy is marvel he's
he's Lord Marvel of the of the Creek and
you would think he would be the same
like Marvel that you recall like the old
original Captain Marvel but he's not
he's a little bit different here and so
what this does is this basically shifts
over to the aftermath of Thanos breaking
out into one of the coolest scenes ever
see here's the thing Rocket Raccoon I
love rocket raccoon rocket racoon in the
comics dude he is hardcore when Thanos
starts going on a rampage starts
attacking everybody like have two
universes so on and so forth ends up
attacking the Peter quill and almost
kind of really starts to choke him at
like almost starts to kill rocket racoon
basically says let him go if you don't
let him go I'm gonna take this this
basically like rampart Arms phasic Han
and I'm gonna fire this thing at you and
while you're not at full strength
this thing's powerful enough to knock
you unconscious and when that happens
I'm gonna put you in a in a cryogenic
chamber and then I'm gonna drop you into
a black hole and you were going to spend
the rest of eternity experiencing
endless life and it's just it's one of
those beastly things ever right because
like Thanos worships death right he
hates the idea of living he wants to die
he's been cursed with immortality by
mistress death at the moments we can't
die but it's like the worst-case
scenario for him right to live for
eternity and so it was just like I'm
going to give you the one thing you fear
the most which is endless life and
ultimately like Thanos ends up backing
off and then you end up having moon
dragon in mantis who use the powers now
those are guys who were unfamiliar with
moon dragon and that's probably a lot of
you guys she's Heather Douglas she's the
daughter of Drax the destroyer and the
way that's played out originally in
Marvel Comics is a Drax the destroyer
was a guy named Arthur Dunn who
alongside his wife and his daughter
we're basically on earth when Thanos
initially launched an attack and all
they were killed in a conflict or at
least Arthur was Heather was believed to
have died but where Arthur was basically
resurrected as as Drax a destroyer the
father of Thanos ends up taking Heather
and then training her inner powers of
telepathy and hand-to-hand combat and
then ultimately she went forward as moon
dragon but in addition to all this stuff
this is when everything really begins to
pop off because where this rift is now
ripped open suddenly all these ships
come pouring out like all these vessels
come pouring out and it's one of the
craziest things because you have Medusa
of the of the Kree Empire who's leaving
it now right like Medusa of the Inhumans
she's like this is an SOS out there to
anybody who can hear us help us for
God's sake get people out here because
what this is it's panic because in
addition to all these ships pouring out
now you have the many angled ones now
here's the crazy thing about it the many
angled ones are what like Shu McGrath is
where a lot of the guys have heard of
Shu McGrath is like this huge big-time
enemy of Doctor Strange under normal
circumstances the many angled ones
occupy the space between universes right
so if you imagine a brick wall you have
the bricks which are all the universes
and the mortar which which holds the
bricks together that's the space between
universes and that's where the mini
angled ones reside but when is it going
on here is these mini angled ones coming
out are extremely powerful right and
highly durable and nothing any of these
guys are doing is really working they're
able to kind of stable off a little bit
but literally it's ship falling after
ship falling this allied you know kind
of coming together this this huge
resistance force of all these empires
across the universe its ship after ship
after ship after ship this collapsing
being destroyed they're literally just
being crushed I mean they're being
absolutely decimated and watching it all
go down watching it all go down is the
Silver Surfer it's one of the coolest
things ever so what you end up doing is
you end up switching directly over to
Marvel talking to this this cancer first
version of quasars but what is up
happening here is Marvel's just kind of
like we have to basically spread our
universe and that's when you kind of
learned that what's going on here is
that at some point in this universe
mistress death died right death was
killed but because death doesn't exist
basically things existed endlessly
nobody was able to die now over time
they began to grow corrupted again all
this explanation will be given to us
once we get into kind of like the
full-on like here's what's going on with
everything but as a result of that
without anything being able to die what
happened is exactly what you would
expect to happen the universe became
overpopulated and because the universe
became overpopulated what this meant is
that it was literally filling to the
brim
and so with that in mind what did what
they've done by this rift being opened
up by by Lord Nagas on behalf of Marvel
from the cancerverse it basically allows
this cancerverse universe to spill into
the main Marvel Universe and to kind of
create this sort of universal conquest
that's really what they're doing is
they're using these kind of faults these
these means to access one universe after
another to kind of spill out and there's
kind of continue on throughout these
different universes more so than that
the overall goal of Lord Marvel is with
every universe he gets him to kill
mistress death in that universe so they
never have to worry about dying and
that's kind of what's going on because
suddenly Peter quill is the one who
figures it out now here's a funny thing
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Peter quill is is not really an idiot so
much it's just kind of like almost like
a class clown in the comics pure quill
is awesome but you he's one of the
coolest guys like dude he's got it
together he's a great tactician by the
guy is legit it wasn't really until you
got into the guardians of the galaxy
film that you saw a Peter quill in the
Marvel Comics start to move closer and
become more like Peter quill in the
movies but the realities that should
have been the other way around Peter
quill in the movies it should be like
the one in the comments because he's a
badass dude he's amazing but he starts
to kind of piece things together and
start to sort of pick up on what's going
on here that with this cancerverse
pouring in into the main Marvel Universe
with a can traverse being a place where
no one can die because mistress death
was killed then the one thing that they
would be afraid of is death itself and
if Thanos is truly the harbinger of
death right if he if he's truly the
avatar of death what he represents what
it means to be unable to die that in
turn what that universe needs is fan OHS
and both Thanos and and Peter quill
figure it out at the same time and so
what we end up doing is jumping back
into the battle again you got all these
guys falling in that's that's that's one
of the things that makes it so cool is
just like none of these guys really seem
to have a have like any hope right like
you jump over to the Nova Corps or at
least what's left of it and the Nova
Corps is being completely overwhelmed
then you have the Ravagers who show up
here and that's the reason why the
Ravagers have been sent in is because
Lord Marvel does not know who the avatar
of death in this universe is to a degree
he's flying in blind he doesn't know
that his Thanos and so as results that
he's like anybody in this universe that
you can find who's died and come back
essentially bring them to me right so
one of the first people they go after is
Naima Rita right the cousin of men with
a submariner
who currently serves on unkind Elida
spacefaring superhero team with the idea
is that she's died and been brought back
before and so because of that she may
very well be an avatar
anybody who's been touched by death in
such a way now the Ravagers themselves
are insanely powerful because you're
talking about beings who can't really
die and insofar as mistress death in
their universe doesn't exist they can
still die here but because of the fact
that they've they've basically been so
long without dying
their durability their strength have
been enhanced multiple times over so
they're much stronger than their main
Marvel counterparts and this is shown
when they basically decimate this team
in no uncertain terms they grab name
arena and they teleport at they're just
like gone like they they end up getting
back out again so that's kind of a funny
thing because then you switch over to
Thanos and that all just kind of like
okay so looking at everything that's
going on here looking at everything
that's transpired here we have to find a
way into that universe I don't really
care about any of the stuff going on we
to find a way to get me into that
universe and to introduce death to that
universe the problem with this is
because Thanos is the avatar of death
his enemy is life right so the best way
to think about this is like the Green
Lantern weakness to the color yellow to
the yellow impurity is really kind of
what this is in relation to life and
death with regards to Thanos and so when
he gets into this universe where it's
riven with life and nothing can die he
basically passes out and ultimately you
know when this team arrives in here
star-lord and drafts a destroyer Gamora
so on and so forth they're met by
another team of the Ravagers which
consists of Valkyrie black panther Shuri
as well as Doctor Strange and The
Incredible Hulk who looks like one of
the coolest versions of the Hulk ever
with like horns and stuff coming out of
his head it is amazing okay so we are
continuing with the Thanos imperative of
the story the most epic vanos story ever
okay so continuing with this battle on
the front lines like this is when stuff
starts to get bananas right it gets it
gets straight-up bananas here think
people who have read this story are just
like dude issue number two is when it
gets crazy I guess absolutely crazy I
really hope you guys are doing this but
of course you you initially pick up with
Richards writer right now here's see
here's the thing this is why people who
were fans of Richard when there were
there were only over two generations of
fans when it came to Richard Rider
people who were fans of him originally
when his stories first came out with
your old fans were people who picked up
with a cosmic landscape from Dan Abnett
and annihilation who became fans at that
point and as some people loved Richard
writers so much right because this guy
goes in when it comes to like facing off
against these various foes and different
things like that and for the most part
he's able to hold his own
but like the front line is
rapidly right like this it's literally
crashing down around them but these many
angled ones are just too difficult to
kill if there was like any other normal
circumstance this this white would have
been over pretty quickly where at the
very least these guys would be able to
hold their own and it wouldn't really be
a stalemate so much as them pushing back
the tide but like these many angled ones
are just too difficult to kill because
they're just so powerful and so where
some of these guys get a blue to rated
suddenly the Silver Surfer comes out of
nowhere right I like comes out of
nowhere
punch is open the math of one of these
things and then like when he's asked by
Nova like are you on our side the Silver
Surfer is like no I'm just a hero forces
have been assemble and that's when you
get like Galactus you get ages u get
tenebrous and you get all of the
Celestials okay so a little bit of
history here for those of you guys who
were unfamiliar with with aegis and
tenebrous because you're probably like
who in the heck of even are these
characters they're hugely powerful right
they're wildly powerful they were
powerful enough to go toe-to-toe with
the Silver Surfer and even fly Galactus
to a bit but the idea was that at the
beginning of all things and this is
something to kind of keep in mind right
we've talked about the ordens of the
universe in the beginnings of life and
there and things like that
and there's different versions of it
right the Asgardians have their own
origin of the universe a Ewing and The
Ultimates form his own origin in the
universe and different things like that
but at the time that this story came out
this was one of many origins right so
you can kind of take it or leave it but
at one point there was a guy there was a
being called dia bleary I think is what
his name was and he was one of what were
called the promeo gods and aegis and
tenebrous stood alongside him along with
a host of others and the idea was that
these beings were mostly prime movers is
really what they were in so far that
their job was to basically set the
universe in motion to where life would
start to form and different things like
that now again we've talked about it at
different origins how like the
Celestials were the ones that did that
and so on and so forth again this is one
of the many origins that are out there
but the idea was once their role as a
prime mover was fulfilled and
essentially the ball was rolling and the
earth I'm sorry that the universe was
off to creating its own life by virtue
of like planets crashing into each other
and different things like that and you
know worlds heating up and single-celled
organisms becoming multi-celled
organisms and so on ultimately there was
no need for them anymore and so what
ended up happening is that D of Larry
alongside are really kind of corrupted
Aegis and tenebrous but kind of brought
them on board to his cause and
essentially instigated a civil war among
the promeo gods this war eventually came
to the doorstep of Galactus who
single-handedly obliterated pretty much
all of them except for ages and
tenebrous who were locked away in the
kiln which is basically this kind of
galactic prison that sits on the very
edge of space for the crunchiest which
is kind of like the the ends of the
universe and so as a result of that they
sat there sort of kept in this prison
for a long long time now all this came
to a head during the story of
annihilation and that's when he started
getting characters like The Fallen who
was like the first Herald of Galactus
who ultimately was imprisoned in the
kiln as well when the annihilation wave
swept through the universe and basically
started like destroying everything he
came across it also led to this kind of
massive prison break at the kiln which
of course saw the Fallen One escape
which led to the whole conflict between
him and Thanos as well as ages and
tenebrous escaping as well now
ultimately they ended up getting until I
kind of a conflict with Galactus of
sorts they fought the Silver Surfer and
then in turn fought Galactus and things
kind of popped off from there but the
power these beings possess is immense
right like ages basically channel's the
the power of the crunch right the power
of the universe's formation more or less
as ambiguous as that is and then
tenebrous channels what's called like
black energy basically the kind of
matter that holds universes together
these are basically long and short end
and really ambiguous and non clear ways
of saying they're cosmic beings like
their cosmic leaf powered beings the
fact that they're here alongside
Galactus and all the Celestials means
that this is a huge event right this is
a massive thing right we don't really
even seen anything like this during
anihilation Rachel it shows just how
huge this conflict is in comparison to
annihilation and we'll talk more about
that here in a second what we end up
doing is jumping over to the cancerverse
itself and picking up with the guardians
of the galaxy alongside Thanos I
remember a nose is essentially
unconscious during this entire conflict
but when you have the guardians of the
galaxy facing off against all these
various people it's cool to see the Dan
out it doesn't just throw it away
right like one of the things he says is
he has like you know what this version
of Doctor Strange being so powerful he
has moondragon user powers to cut the
the telepathic abilities I've never even
telepathic but to kind of keep the mind
to these guys close so that if anybody
out there is listening to what's going
on kind of keeping track by it by
maintaining a link with their mental
minds did that link will basically break
off and so as a result to that mantas
steps in she shuts down Doctor Strange
and the conflict basically unfolds from
there and it's a cool thing to see
because he's characters for the most
part go toe to toe albeit they're all
defeated by the guardians of the galaxy
and so when that happens a Guardians
essentially kill them all but remember
they're in a cancerverse
they're in an in a universe where
nothing can ever die and so what is up
happening is that with these various
forces once they're all quote/unquote
believed to have been dead they
basically mutate and then rise
yeah and that's kind of how things
continually go right every time you kill
something and mutates and then it comes
back so that's when Thanos starts to
wake up and it's a cool thing because
these guys are basically like I don't
know who this guy is
but he scares the crap outta me it's one
of the coolest things because Stannis
basically uses all of his power and just
blasts these guys into oblivion and what
this does is it basically says stano's
as the living avatar of death can bring
death to the cancerverse and that's why
it is that Marvel and his forces are
trying to capture the avatar of death
because as the avatar of death he
basically is death in human form right
so he's like if mistress death became a
person and decided to walk around he
channels her power to bring death to
everything and so what that means is
that if you were to go toe-to-toe
against Lord Marvell and win then he
would ultimately end up killing Lord
Marvell as well as anybody else in the
cancerverse
that's why they were afraid of him
that's why they want to remove him from
the board but it's also why he's
important and we'll talk about why danos
is the single most important character
due at the entirety of this story
because in the middle of all this one
ends up happening is their sin we met by
the arrival of the vision who simply
says I'm not here to bring you any harm
what it does after that is it jumps back
to the major conflict on the wall right
to the front line of the fault and like
all these forces that are pouring
through and this is one of the single
coolest parts of the story Institute is
amazing how cool this is right because I
mean I mean look at this landscape of
forces here right like you've got all
these major empires who are doing the
best they can just to live right it's
kind of the similarities between this
and annihilation in annihilation all
this crazy the story picked up with like
basically refugee groups just like
fleeing for their lives and just trying
to stay alive that's what's happening
here right like they're doing the best
they can but it's just an is an absolute
massacre about anything I've ever
watched Star Trek
if you guys remember Star Trek first
contact with like the board we're
heading towards Earth and just
annihilating the Federation ships and
they were just sending out SOS is all
over the place and it's like anybody who
could help us just please like anyone it
doesn't even matter who you are just
help us like that's literally what this
is just like somebody somewhere help us
and so you have all these various forces
coming in but it's kind of a funny thing
because one of the things is commented
on by Nova as well as we know Vaughn is
that like the fact that these entities
are here the fact that cosmic entities
have stepped in really shows the
significance of this event that's going
on here and what this means is a solar
surfer kind of chimes in and he says
it's not just
this universe the reason why the cosmic
entities are here is because it's not
just this universe that's at stake it's
all the universes that are at stake as
well now here's the important thing to
understand and this is the question
people are going to ask where is the
Living Tribunal in all of this right
because you would think if one universe
managed to invade another universe that
ultimately the Living Tribunal would
step in and say there's a magical
imbalance here no that's not the way it
works because remember the linee
tribunals job is not to keep universes
separate it's not to keep universes from
crossing over with each other the living
tribunals job is to maintain magical
balance right to maintain magical energy
there and so in this circumstance the
mistress death because of the way that
she was killed and because of why she
died in in the cancerverse universe
which we'll talk about Oh what this
basically means is that like the natural
order of things was more or less
maintained that where the Silver Surfer
says their actions are unnatural it's
not true at least it's not not the case
and as it pertains to the Living
Tribunal but the reality is if the
universe can't maintain itself against
an external force then the universe will
succumb to whatever that external force
happens to be it's the natural order of
things the weak make way for the strong
is how things have always worked it's
the the the rule of logic letting
tribunal of hide when it came to Thanos
using the Infinity stones and then
wanting to take over the role of
eternity right during the original
Infinity Gauntlet story if eternity was
empower 'full enough to maintain its
role then Thanos would replace it and
that's basically what's going on here
albeit from one universe to another as
opposed to from one galaxy to another or
one planet to another within a universe
itself and so that's why things are so
huge is because in the midst of all this
what you suddenly have is this kind of
coalescing like this kind of coming out
with regards to some entity or some
force passing through the rift itself
and when everybody starts to look up and
everybody starts to panic everybody
starts to freak wondering what this is
we end up finding out they have every
reason to freak out because what's
coming out of this giant rift is the
Galactus engine okay so continuing on
with our coverage of the Pharos
imperative we get to the moment you've
all been waiting for the origin of the
cancer verse how did it all start how
did we get to this point I imagine a lot
of the guys who really really want to
know what's going on so before we get
into that we pick up with the aftermath
of the Galactus engine and again this is
one of the coolest things and what
really shocked me when I first saw this
was just how huge the Galactus engine
was right this idea that it absolutely
like all the cosmic entities in size but
the funny thing about this is that you
have like Nova and you have these guys
who are who really like fighting this
fight and watching this whole thing go
down and in their minds they look at the
Galactus engine and it doesn't really
look like it's doing anything where the
comment of the Silver Surfer is it's
fighting all the cosmic entities on a
different plane of existence now this is
why this matters this is one of those
things that you get into you when it
comes to the cosmic entities right but
the cosmic entities as you perceive them
don't really exist that way they do but
they don't
the cosmic entities are really more
representations of concepts they don't
really have a true physical form but
when it comes to these conflicts with
these cosmic entities what they have are
what are called embodies and embodies
are basically the physical form that
cosmic entities take on that are given
to them is they go to a place called the
dimension of manifestations and this
place is ran by a guy named
anthropomorphic and anthropomorphism a
physical body now if you thing to
understand here is that we don't really
understand how time passes and the
dimension of manifestations but
basically from the time they leave the
main Marvel Universe go to that
dimension get a physical body and come
back is instantaneous right like it
happens as far as the normal human or
the normal being is concerned in the
blink of an eye right it's just is that
quick but that's what you're basically
seeing here so what you're seeing is not
really a physical fight between the
cosmic entities and the Galactus engine
so much is like a metaphysical fighter I
kind of taking taking place in a higher
plane and that's why the the indecision
is kind of standing there but this
massive conflicts taking place because
ultimately Aegis is the first one to
fall and so when she's destroyed what
you end up seeing at least as best as
people can normally perceive it is you
see like this giant being kind of break
its way out from inside of her and
that's kind of how that goes down it's a
little funky and it's not what you would
expect it'd be a lot easier if it was
just shooting lasers out of his eyes and
hitting cosmic entities but that was a
nature of Dan Abnett riding right to
kind of perceive it you know destroy us
as you would normally see it and so what
this does is this goes directly into the
origin of the cancer verse itself and
what we're now doing here is picking up
with Thanos and and the rest of the
guardians of the galaxy when they
arrived in the cancer versus version of
Titan this is one of the things that's
kind of cooled because for the most part
it all really kind of seems to function
in the same capacity the difference here
is that vision was created on Titan
vision was not created on earth right so
the indication here is that Ultron never
existed right because Ultron was the one
who created vision who in turn was sent
to attack the Avengers the avengers
basically swayed vision to their side
and then vision in the avengers defeated
Ultron here it doesn't seem to have been
the case now
what we're basically given here to
envisions talking to everybody vanos
envision kind of come to this
realization right Thanos says only one
of two things possibly could have
happened in this universe that led to
endless life either it means life itself
uh somehow been empowered right so
people have somehow found a way to make
themselves immortal or in his vision
puts that death was killed and that's
what you end up getting here now the
funny thing about this is you kind of
have to read between the lines and you
have to read very very closely to really
understand what Dan Abbott's saying
what's going on which is why I'm here so
what it up happening in this universe
winded up happening in this universe
here is that Marvel as you know much
much like this that the main Marvel
Universe ended up developing cancer now
in the main Marvel Universe Marvel died
right it was a story in 1984 called the
death of Captain Marvel it was a
landmark story in Marvel Comics are a
lot of really old Captain Marvel fans
loved it but but the idea was that
Marvel had essentially developed cancer
and then died from it but the idea here
is that in this event in the way that
this takes place is that unlike the main
marvel universe where Marvel simply
succumb to his cancer surrounded by all
of his superhero friends more or less
that what had happened was he had
basically been reached out to you by the
many angled one so many angled ones
contacted him and said you can live if
you kill death it's the only way to
ensure that you survive and so kind of
being corrupted by them and basically
falling falling down and kind of
becoming this guy that fell to his
darker side why because in the main
Marvel Universe it was more of a more or
less accepting it once the time came and
saying this is the natural order of
things is the way things are supposed to
go I know it sucks guys but hey you
wouldn't some you lose some and so
because of that in this instance he
didn't do that he gave in to his really
to his to his weaker self his desire to
live and so ultimately took the hands of
all the various superheroes who were
there and then modified them in such a
way to where they became the versions
that you see now and then following that
basically empowering them they ended up
killing the avatar of death the ended of
sacrificing human what was in a ritual
called a necropsy
which basically led to its destruction
now we're kind of led to believe because
the ceremony took place on sanctuary
which is the ship of Thanos that in that
universe the avatar of death was down as
well we're not explicitly told who it
was or something just told that the
avatar of death was destroyed the result
here is that with this avatar being
destroyed so too was mistress death it
had kind of a shockwave mistress death
died in this alternate reality and the
result was that nobody could die anymore
but the side effect of this and what it
did is it allowed the many angled ones
to pour into that universe and when that
happened everybody became corrupted by
their power
and everybody ended up becoming the most
evil and dark versions of themselves
hence the reason why you see them acting
the way that they do and so that's how
this entire universe came into existence
is because death was basically destroyed
in an alternate reality now it's
interesting and it kind of flies in the
face of conventional wisdom because what
we've seen in the years following this
story is that mistress death can't die
right so during the incursions that
collapse of the multiverse Jonathan
Hickman defenders of New Avengers
mistress death was the one cosmic entity
the beyonders couldn't kill so long as
you know people could die and so on and
so forth no the reality is she kind of
served the role as a plot device in that
story the multiverse had to end and so
it was kind of hard to destroy and kill
everything in the multiverse if nothing
can die right so it kind of made sense
to keep mistress death alive on that
score but the fact remains here that
ultimately the actions of Thanos in the
guardians of the galaxy draw the
attention of Marvel when a kind of
messengers of sources received in the
sense that like their team that was
there has essentially been destroyed
communications been cut off and of
course Scarlet Witch ends up sending a
team to investigate following that so
the cool thing about this and this is
one reason why fans loved Richard Reiter
so much again kind of capitalizing what
we had before was it following the front
line of the fall right following the
destruction of Ages are the fact that
all these forces are there for the most
part it sent the entire United Front
into retreat more or less everybody
panic right because like a cosmic entity
was was obliterated now and the question
being asked was is what if a cosmic
entity could be destroyed by this
Colossus engine which Hans's anybody
else have and so what well they they
have kind of retreated it's not really
giving up is simply the Allied counsel
of war right it's coming together and
say okay what's the next step
what do we do now now there's a lot of
infighting that ends up going on there
right because Medusa is essentially like
the new ruler of the Kree since black
bolts out of commission and basically
missing following the events of the war
in realm of kings also she's the one
ruling in a stead but she's a new ruler
as far as anybody else is concerned so
the old kings don't really see her as
somebody who's battle-hardened or
experienced it don't really have a whole
lot of respect for it at the same time
you've got like blastaar who's basically
like I've achieved in more or less so if
he's fine with just pillaging and
plundering everything you have all these
different ideologies in terms of how
these guys function and ultimately where
they're all squabbling amongst
themselves
Richard Reiter is the one who shows up
and says everybody shut up we gotta
figure out what we're gonna do here and
it's one of the cool things because when
it comes to these kind of war councils
he's kind of war chieftains more or less
that what it really comes down to is how
authoritative can you be how much
command can you respect and then like do
you have it together and that's why
Richard Rider people who read his
character who picked up with
elation loved him because at the
beginning of annihilation he wasn't
really careless and reckless so much as
a guy who was just there and didn't
really understand a full gravity of how
bad things could get but then when the
entire night like the entire Nova Corps
was obliterated right he was the only
one left he had to rise to the challenge
he had to rise and become like the best
version of himself and so for people who
followed his character and what they saw
was that the character of Richard Rider
evolving and growing ultimately what
winds up happening here is that in the
face of what's going on Richard Reiter
basically says look there's a couple of
things that I picked up with the
destruction of Ages this kind of
telepathic energy basically resonated in
within me and gave me a kind of cosmic
awareness and let me realize that what's
going on here is that while we're
fighting on this whole front that the
the forces of Marvel himself are
basically traveling around and they're
gathering various individuals who in
some form of fashion have been touched
by death and so we have to basically
grab these guys because we have to
figure out what's going on here and what
the grand scheme of this guy Marvel is
because what's going on here is not the
end game that's not what's that's not
the main goal of what's going on and so
what you end up getting here is a kind
of coming together if not a slight bit
of a return of a group called the
annihilators now the annihilators were a
ridiculously overpowered team right it
was ridiculous how powerful they were
right you had quasar who's a cosmic
being you had beta ray bill who's
basically like this super power for a
powerful for yeah gladiator it
essentially speaks for itself
Silver Surfer and Ron and the accuser
they were the original original
annihilators and they were hugely
powerful Nova bring them together it's
cool but the idea of the annihilators
was designed to be a kind of extension
of the guardians of the galaxy right in
the sense of star-lord wanted a team
following the events of annihilation and
annihilation conquest that would serve
the purpose of like protecting the
galaxy team in the universe from various
threats that were out there the problem
is that with the Guardians themselves
while they weren't interesting and they
were cool and they were composed of some
various members they weren't all
powerful what you needed was a team that
was insanely powerful and so forming the
annihilators did that because what
you're talking about here are some of
the most powerful beings in the entirety
of Marvel Comics by the annihilators
themselves could take on pretty much all
comers right I mean these guys were
insanely not to terms of the abilities
they possessed and so as a result so
that this team is designed for the
mission a really for for a strike force
of going in and basically grabbing all
these individuals who have been taken by
lord Marvel and his forces you know to
basically try to complete the necropsy
by killing what they
to be the avatar of death to get in get
out and basically do what they can and
so following that what you end up doing
is jumping back to the cancerverse
itself and this is when things go awry
because with everything that's happening
here and everything going on
Thanos understands a couple things the
first is that going through with this
mission to basically undo the necropsy
right to bringing death to the various
forces that cancerverse means going back
to where it all started right were the
original necropsy took place on
sanctuary and then essentially taking
out Marvel or whoever else they can by
introducing death to them but it may
also be one of those things where
there's no coming back from this right
like fan OHS may actually end up dying
here if mistress death decides to
reverse her impact and make him mortal
again and so if that's the case then
what do you wanted to do is basically
settle all debts that's basically what's
going on here and because Jack's a
destroyer just kind of been muttering to
himself the entire time and expressed in
this desire to kill thanos which has not
gone unnoticed
damos response is if there's something
you want to say then say it man like I
mean everyone if you got something to
say bring this beef to the table we can
cook it right we can grill it we can we
can we can deal with this you know and
it'll turn out one of two ways one of us
ain't gonna walk out of here alive and
I'm the only one here who's really
immortal do what you got to do and like
a fight breaks out between the two of
them now initially you have like mantis
and Cosmo trying to step in Cosmo of
course being the Russian cosmonaut dog
with telepathy he's really really cool
but they basically try to intervene
using their telepathy or using the
ability of mantas to manipulate emotions
and it doesn't work right because their
power is just way too way to be on there
right like Drax's is really able to kind
of block telepathic attacks and Thanos
he's just so powered up now so amped up
that he can't really be defeated can't
really be calmed down or controlled by
any kind of telepath out there barring
you know Jean Grey is a Phoenix force or
something like that and so where you
have Drax she basically attaches a kind
of antimatter device onto phantos that
what this does is it literally emits
antimatter energy right like this idea
that once once antimatter comes into
contact with positive matter it'll
basically wipe it out it will cease to
exist and so when that's the case this
device is attached Thanos Drax fulfills
his mission and his idea of killing
Thanos and keeping him dead and
basically eradicate some kills Thanos on
the spot basically destroying
everybody's hopes of being able to
defeat all the forces of the cancerverse
okay so we're jumping into Thanos
imperative part for part patro and uh
yes so we continue on our journey with
the cancerverse
and everything now here's a
think this picks up in in the main
Marvel Universe which is actually where
Marvel and all his forces are at and
assume joins up with with them
essentially like grabbing a Morita
November knew Morita is one of many
people they think are the avatar of
death right and so at this point it's
you know tell us what's going on give us
your anomaly right and that's the idea
here is that those individuals who are
either outside the space-time continuum
meaning they're not supposed to be in
this universe because they come from
might a different universe or something
like that or individuals who have been
touched by death in return or considered
to have anomalies these these sort of
homing beacons to a degree that allow
the the revenger z-- the members of the
camp servers to track them down locate
them and then take them the issue with
this is that it's picked up almost
immediately right off the bat when it
comes to Marvel that name Arita is not
the the avatar of death right it's not
her but the idea is she can possibly
lead them to to the avatar or something
along those lines the issue with all
this is that in the middle of it all
that's when the annihilators arrived and
the annihilators start unleashing all
kinds of different problems now here's
the cool thing is we get these little
cameos here in there right like you
basically get like the ravager version
of venom at the version of it and they
can't die and this venom of course is
well I guess kind of can die this venom
is more or less taken out by a by Ron
and the accuser you get the ravager
versions of the x-men right so like the
cancerous versions of the x-men the
funny thing about this is that this
version of the x-men actually shows up
in war of realms the Imperial Guard but
it's kind of a quick little thing is
it's not a great big huge thing I mean
it is to a degree but seeing like seeing
the x-men is not nearly that interesting
it's not what you would think it would
be but essentially all these forces of
Marvel are dealt with quite readily by
the annihilators because again you're
talking about a vast amount of power
being used now remember these guys can't
truly die so what they do when they
destroy them is they more or less
incapacitate them and then ultimately
all these different foes will return the
problem with this and what really seems
to come to a head here is that
ultimately Marvel begins to pick up on
the fact that essentially Thanos was
killed inside of the cancerverse
and so him having the kind of connection
to the cancer verse that he does he
immediately realizes what's going on and
then says like the avatar of death the
reason why we can't find him is because
the avatar of death is in our universe
he's not here now so they basically say
like let's go like let's teleport away
so they end up teleporting away directly
to the cancerverse itself the funny
thing is that we saw Santos die at the
hands of Drax the destroyer but remember
Santos can't die and so that this really
kind of answers the question what
happens when a person is banned from the
realm of mistress death and there's
essentially dies through conventional
meats right like what happens to them
like with something like this when when
their body is totally disintegrated the
result is that their body reforms now
there's precedent for this and this
comes from the story or really comes by
way of the story funeral for free from
Deadpool right so to sidetrack here for
a second Deadpool was ultimately cursed
with immortality by Thanos himself
because of the fact that mistress death
was in love with Deadpool and she wasn't
in love with Thanos right so that was
being angry about that cursed ah
Deadpool immortality so that when
Deadpool was destroyed and all that was
left with his hand his body we grew from
his hand right so that's where this
really comes from this that that kind of
laid the groundwork for this sort of
situation now it really kind of depends
on on who's writing the story when you
looked at fan OHS having been Hearst
with immortality and then you had the
events of like the incursions and the
collapse of the multiverse when all that
came to an end in Thanos was
quote-unquote destroyed by by God King
doom during the events of secret Wars he
didn't really die because he couldn't go
to their own mistress death but he
didn't reconstitute instead what ended
up happening is he was banished to a
realm that was basically oblivion it was
a place beyond the entirety of the
multiverse just this giant empty void is
really what it was and so because of
that when the events of all-new
all-different marvel took place and
Thanos returned during the Avengers
stories he literally broke out of that
realm that kind of giant void and then
showed up in the main Marvel Universe
right so it depends on who's writing the
story is it's the nature of comics
there's no hard and fast rule here it
just depends on what's going on and how
a particular writer wants to take things
in a particular direction but then I'll
show him back up here of course he's
pissed because of the fact that Drax
killed him he's always like okay that's
the kind of game you want to play then
let's play the game and he just totally
eradicated Drax the destroyer right just
totally annihilates this guy and
destroys him and so in the aftermath of
that you had the annihilators really
kind of grabbing those individuals who
have been taken by lord Marvel and when
more my villain had taken off ultimately
when the annihilators are making their
escape lord Marvel quite literally pops
in this is one last thing and detonates
the ship blows up the ship seemingly
killing everybody on board but what is
it going on here is that with all the
other members of the team being here
let's say all the forces of Thanos all
these guys being back in this
cancerverse their nature their situation
leads to the arrival of the revenger
'he's
really kind of the the I guess the
forward team being sent by Marvel in so
far as like war machine and Hawkeye and
Captain America as well as Scarlet Witch
herself now this is where things get
really interesting here because with
this
massive battle that breaks out with this
massive battle that's going on here what
we end up finding out is the Scarlet
Witch is to a degree kind of a traitor
in the in the sense that what took place
here is the Scarlet Witch was never
really on the side of all the various
superheroes and what's gonna switch gets
there and finds that that vision has
basically been destroyed then we end up
finding out she was a spy the entire
time that when Marvel had undergone the
process of warping all the superheroes
in his universe in the cancerverse
and then in turn you know basically
killed death and then brought in the
mini angled ones MIT Scarlet Witch had
essentially stood there as a kind of spy
of sorts and so that's why she ended up
leading these various field teams is
because what she was always trying to do
was try to find you know one try to find
a way to make contact with vision again
and then to report her findings and try
to find a way to work along or at least
you know serve her role alongside the
resistance and that's what's been going
on the entire time and so when this goes
down she literally destroys all the
other superheroes who were there where
like all the other revenge errs
basically incapacitates and destroys
Alden at least as best you can and then
in turn joins the the Guardians
themselves now of course they're
hesitant right I mean you got this chick
who's basically like a skewed warped bad
guy but vision chimes in and says she's
been working with the resistance since
the very beginning you can trust her
everything will be okay the reality of
this is because the betrayal of the
Scarlet Witch what's going to happen
here the fate that's going to be gonna
be bestowed upon her is that she'll be
taken by the many angled ones and
what'll end up happening is her soul
will be torn apart and it'll be it'll be
tortured and she'll experience pain
beyond imagining for the rest of
eternity
right for all of existence it's gonna be
the worst possible fate that she could
ever experience we're just having her
soul torn apart over and over and over
again but ultimately it's the sacrifice
she makes because in truth she believes
that what's going on here with Marvel
and everything taking place is wrong and
it's an inherently bad thing and so what
is up happening if she basically says
here's one final gambit exhausting my
powers doing what I can I'm going to
teleport all of you to the realm of or
the first and necropsy took place the
first instance of mistress death being
destroyed in this universe the place
they have to go to in order to reverse
the entire process at the same time kind
of a cool little thing here sort of an
explanation that in terms of the
annihilators in the various forces who
seemed to be destroyed all that really
went on here is that Windell von himself
and and it really is as quantum bands of
sorts to kind of channel everybody's
power and they create a kind of cocoon
for themselves to basically safeguard
them and keep them alive right we're
just well within the power of
the quantum bands but the cool thing
about this is what's still going on on
the front lines and it's very easy to
forget about that with everything else
taking place right to forget about
what's happening in the front line of
the fault in this giant battle did in
reality this Galactus engine is still
there and it's still destroying these
cosmic entities that none of them really
seem to be able to stand a chance that
most of the forces that are there around
half the forces of all these various
groups this part or the Kree the the the
forces of blast are so on and so forth
the Shiar they've all basically been
obliterated right half their forces are
pretty much gone and they're fighting
with really what amounts to a skeleton
crew is really all this left
it's what little forces they can to
stave off against this massive threat
the cosmic entities some of them have
already fled right some of them have
already left and said I'm we can't fight
this like we can't win this war and so
what you end up getting is back on the
cancerverse itself you end up having
kind of this this location that's met by
by Thanos on all of these various forces
and the idea is okay let's fight this
conflict and let's see where this goes
and so ultimately when they arrive there
at this location they end up finding
that the place is kind of uh not really
living and it's not really dead people
were just kind of or at least what's
there is kind of in this sort of state
of limbo more or less it's kind of the
the strange scenario that goes on not
only that we also end up learning that
when Marvel finally shows up that
basically Thanos was the embodiment or
was the avatar of death in that universe
right so Thanos in that universe was
basically destroyed by Marvel and
presumably it worked out the way that
Thanos wanted it to right I mean we'd
have to believe given the nature of
Thanos that he was okay with it right
spending an eternity with mistress death
was something that was highly you know
sought after by him and so the result is
that where you end up having the the
guardians or at least Nova who sits down
and sort of looks at this transmission
that was left behind by star-lord and
saying you know me and the guardians
would grab Thanos we took off to the
cancerverse
we're gonna try to find a way to undo
all of this and he invites Richard Ryder
along Richard Ryder ends up going to the
cancer verse to fight alongside
star-lord essentially one last time and
so this conflict this this huge battle
is pretty hardcore right because
literally they're fighting to keep
Thanos alive and they're fighting to
defend off against these guys who really
can't die right if all these forces die
then it'll basically be the end of it
all because seemingly Thanos can't hold
all of them off on his own so it's a
pretty huge gambit but what is it going
on this is this is one of the crazy
things what is up happening here is that
in the middle of this giant battle
suddenly Dano stops and Thanos says
please give me the one thing that I can
have the power you guys have in this
universe is astronomical because now
you're back
the mini angled one these these insanely
powerful artifacts she's insanely
powerful objects if in your universe you
had the means to kill the avatar of
death insofar as it bypassed the power
of mistress death then please do that
grant me the death that I seek kill me
and so ultimately Thanos ends up giving
up basically ends up releasing Marvel
and ultimately ends up bending the knee
and joining his side
okay so we are at the conclusion of the
Thanos imperative yes we are we are at
the end of this story and the ending is
amazing it is so cool okay so
danos giving up and joining the side of
Marvel and the revenge errs and the
cancerverse people were kind of freaking
out about it they were starting to kind
of lose their minds and here's a funny
thing about this Marvel's response is
like thank you I appreciate everything
that you're doing to help me out you
know I'll take you and I'll take all
your friends and all of my guys are like
all my mini angled ones are so anxious
to meet you what this means is a mini
angled ones can basically transcend the
existing universe and move into another
universe
remember multiversal conquests is the
name of the game going from one universe
to the next conquering it and taking it
over the other question was how in the
world were they able to kill the avatar
of death in the first place was it just
means of overpowering them with with
cosmic energy or anything like that no
it was basically an artifact a weapon
that was provided to Marvel by the many
angled ones themselves specifically by
Shu McGrath now this kind of requires us
to get into a bit of discussion about
the nature of Shu McGrath right so if
you go back and you look at like 1970
you look in 1981 by 1970 you had a
slimming tower it was issue number six
but it was written by Wally wood and the
idea was that he was the one that first
kind of referenced the Dark Gods so to
speak in the Marvel Comics you go into
Bruce Jones in 1981 with a Conan story
and you get like the Dark One's you know
the old ones that kind of a thing it was
always kind of Marvel eluding over the
years so they were like these Dark Gods
that were out there it wasn't really
until Grant Morrison with Zenith and it
wasn't really until you sort of getting
into like Doctor Strange stories with
with Shu McGrath that these old ones
these dark primordial gods sort of kind
of getting a form the idea of referring
to them as the many angled ones in in
this one and in cancerverse and Thanos
imperative is actually a relatively new
concept but all it's designed to do is
kind of consolidate all this information
down and to say the Shu McGrath is one
of many of these beings that
just out there in the space between
universes but unlike a lot of these many
angled ones if there is a hierarchy we
don't really know about it but we do
know that Xu McGrath for the most part
led them now in terms of how Xu McGrath
ties into this it could largely kind of
be assumed that like multiple occasions
where Xu McGrath was always sort of
trying to break into the main Marvel
Universe this is yet another instance
you know the difference is that Shiva
McGrath was always kind of a multi
versatile entity and that because he
resides in the space between universes
he doesn't really belong to a particular
universe right so we can kind of move
between universes as he as he sees fit
as he can it just happens to be with a
lot of the Doctor Strange stories or at
least they're really old stories he was
always trying to pass him to the main
Marvel Universe conquer it since that's
where he ruled at one point and they
kind of branch out from there right but
one of the things this kind of been hit
on with the idea of the the cancer verse
is that Xu McGrath and the many angled
ones have conquered multiple other
universes right this is just one in a
long line of different universes they're
trying to take over some of them are
much much darker and far more screwed up
in this one and some of them remain
untouched right so it's one of those
strange situations but giving a Marvel a
sword by which he can kill the avatar of
death is magically empowered and that's
one of the things to understand here is
that while you do have cosmic entities
and you do have various beings out there
that are wildly powerful you do also
have a lot of demons and things like
that that are equally powerful right so
there that you know the cosmic entities
aren't really like the Grand Poobah the
buck doesn't stop there there's a lot of
beings out there that are equally
powerful to them right it's one of the
things we didn't really include and the
Marvel cosmic hierarchy is like a lot of
the demons and monsters that are equal
to a lot of the cosmic entities and we
probably should you know it kind of kind
of do it because we need to do a new
cosmic hierarchy anyway so we'll
probably go ahead and jump into that but
the idea here is using this sword that
was given to him by the many angled ones
Marvel in turn stabs Thanos and so what
it does is it jumps to that basically
the opening of the fault and then it
basically picks up with the Galactus
engine and the idea here is that with
with this basically being kind of a
warped and and screwed up version of
Galactus himself from the main Marvel
Universe but albeit from a different
reality what it does is it actually sees
a lot of the other cosmic entities stand
aside and it loves Galactus to engage in
a conflict with this now the reason why
is because Galactus unlike a lot of
these other cosmic entities really kind
of takes it as like a personal a
personal battle right a personal
struggle more so than that the Galactus
really seems you one of the few left
standing a lot of the other cosmic
entities either been destroyed or
they've left for example
and the judge of the Celestials was
destroyed or at least seemed to be
destroyed in this conflict and so a lot
of the Celestials have been obliterated
a lot of the other cosmic entities have
been destroyed Galactus is one of the
last few standing and so ultimately what
ends up happening here with all these
other these other forces that are here
that she are what they end up doing is
saying okay then our job here is to
focus on the Galactus engine this is the
single biggest threat that we had to
face here everything else is cleanup
duty and comparison to this but this is
the biggest threat because this is what
can wipe out the cosmic entities and
sort of joining all their forces
together and working to try to destroy
the Galactus engine at the end of the
day all they're really able to do is
kind of offer some measure of aid but
they're not really able to do it on
their own right because there's just too
much power for them to contain so that's
the nature of the conflict at the moment
right now it looks like all hope is lost
the Afghan owes who essentially joined
forces and is into sacrificing himself
to Marvel you have all these forces you
have like almost all the cosmic entities
who in a lot of ways been destroyed
you've got Galactus is one of the few
left half the forces that are there have
been totally eradicated just by the
forces of the cancer force coming out
not even like Galactus engine itself and
then once Galactus and the other cosmic
entities are destroyed then every all
these of the forces will be wiped out I
mean for the most part all hope is lost
here it's bleak it's one of these things
where like everybody's going to die now
of course Nova's showing up here and
offering a helping hand it's cool but
he's by no means powerful enough on his
own to save the day and the real gambit
here the real trick comes by way of
stano's and this is why this is why one
is called the Thanos imperative and to
wife a knows in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe was painfully underplayed
because thou is exceedingly intelligent
he's one of the smartest people out
there in the Marvel Universe in terms of
battle strategy and all those things and
the reason why is because remember all
this this conflict with Thanos the
revenge errs and all that stuff is
taking place inside the cancerverse
and so ultimately what he does is he
begins to kind of tease and toy with
Marvel and say here's so much like my
main Marvel counterpart and when the
question is asked why is it because
Marvel always jumped headlong into his
goal and he never really considered the
consequences he never really thought
about what it was that he was doing by
killing me here in your universe all
you've done is invite mistress death
you've brought death to a universe where
people can't die were you killed a
mistress death that's here you've sealed
your own fate it's the smartest gambit
that could have been made here the
smartest thing that could have been done
because Thanos saw this coming and it
was part of his plan
entire time right I mean it was
something that kind of came to fruition
as soon as Thanos realized that he was
banned from the realm of mistress death
and he couldn't die
it's why he instigated the fight with
that with Drax the destroyer was to test
that theory was to test the theory can
he die you know as the avatar of death
and as someone who had been banned from
the realm of mistress death what would
happen if his physical body was
destroyed
would it reconstitute itself would he be
kind of left is some sort of spiritual
essence whatever the case was it was a
huge risk to take but that was the idea
behind it was to basically engage into a
fight with Drax the destroyer let doctor
to destroy her kill him and then see
what happens the fact that his physical
body resurrected meant the Thanos
himself could not truly die his physical
form would always return meaning he
could go to the cancer verse he could
lead Marvel to his location if Marvel
was anything like the main Marvel
Universe version that they must have
fought so many times he would have done
exactly what he did
Thanos knew exactly what he would do
which is exactly what he did and jump
the gun celebrate in the fact that oh my
god I finally got the avatar of death
let's kill him and give no thought to
like what happens if we do kill him in
this location the smart move would have
been to take Thanos to the main Marvel
Universe and kill him there because in
that way mistress death wouldn't have
been teleported it wouldn't have been
brought to that universe but remember
it's the nature of mistress death as the
person who gathers the souls of those
who have died to travel to their
location and to bring them to where
they're supposed to be is exactly what
it of happening with regards to the
original Marvel and so because of that
with this version of Marvel having
brought mistress death to his universe
she in turn kills him and then wipes out
everything is supposed to die everything
they're supposed to be cleared out and
because this is a universe where
everything is supposed to be dead even
though it's not ultimately the entire
universe ends up getting wiped out by
mistress death it's all cleanse and it's
all cleared out right like everything in
that universe is for the most part
destroyed or at least is what it seems
and so far as the universe begins to
collapse in on itself all the members
who are there as part of the cancerverse
either inside the cancerverse universe
or in the main Marvel Universe are
killed the Galactus engine itself begins
to be pulled back in the many angled
ones seemed a more or less retreat or be
eradicated themselves essentially the
day appears to be one and this is where
things begin to go awry because what
happens here is Thanos turns to mistress
death and says I fulfilled my purpose as
your avatar I've done these things to
please you will you talk to me a
mistress death still turns away mistress
death still says no it's the age-old
struggle between Thanos and mistress
death he's trying to get her attention
and she won't give it to him and so
as a result of that he begins to lash
out the crazy thing about this is
stanols is now in a maddened state which
means when all these forces start
getting teleported out of this location
if Thanos goes with them or if Thanos
makes it through the Rift and returns
back to the main Marvel Universe who
knows what he's gonna do because he's
angry and he's heartbroken so just go on
some warpath and start killing
everything he can find but because of
that what ends up happening here is Nova
in star-lord end up staying behind the
Cosmic Cube as it was brought in by
star-lord for just just for this kind of
situation in case it was needed with
what little power it has left is
basically used in channel for the
purpose of keeping Thanos contained
keeping Thanos subdued and so as the
entire universe begins collapsing in
down around them and as as the fault
begins to seal and as everything is cut
off ultimately Richard Ryder and Peter
quill stay behind in the cancerverse
with Thanos and are basically trapped
there and ultimately the day is saved
right so because of the sacrifice of
these two guys the entire cancerverse is
more or less defeated the victory is won
by the various superheroes and of course
a statue is made in their name but the
big takeaway from this and the thing
that kind of left a lot of people asking
was what comes next what happens with
star-lord what happened Richard Ryder
and what happens with Thanos are they
gone from the Marvel landscape forever
or are they going to make a return with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain it make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the rock or if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like this was an
amazing story and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]